- What do I know about heels?
- Oh Lord, Jesus!
- I know they shouldn't be on me.
- Look at that blister!
- My feet are already red.
- Oh! (bleep) Don't trip Please!
- Help!
- Can I get some assistance, please?
- Nothing that good looking
could be could be comfortable.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know what the (bleep)
I'm getting myself into.
- From what I understand, the high heels
are very uncomfortable when
worn over a long period of time.
- I'm done.
- I just gotta start
saying,"No," to (bleep).
- You want your calves to look great?
You want your ass to be lifted up?
Your feet are gonna hurt a little bit.
- I can't.
- I woke up this morning and I stood
in front of my closet for like 10 minutes.
Like, what goes with heels?
- Did they really have to be this sparkly?
- I think it's gonna be awesome.
I think I'm gonna feel tall,
which is, I mean, the
silent hope of every man.
- As long as I do better
than Ryan, I don't care.
- This is a (bleep) mess.
How am I supposed to walk in this?
(women laughing)
- You're calling attention to me.
Just get away from me!
- Hi ladies.
(women admiring)
- [voiceover] Your calves look amazing.
- Oh, thank you! Did you hear that?
I already go complimented on my calves.
I'm in heels and we're
having an earthquake drill.
Oh, God.
- Earthquake!
Ryan, wait, it's an earthquake!
- My feet are sweating,
are your feet sweating?
- Oh, yeah.
It's not the only thing
sweating right now.
- My heels are sinking into the grass.
- I'm sinking!
- Will! Will!
- Dude, it's like standing in quicksand.
- Yeah, where's Bergara.
Bergara! You son of a (bleep)!
Ryan! Where are your shoes?
- They were lost in the wreckage.
- Uh-huh.
- This is my life right now.
- We're midway through the day right now.
I don't feel great.
My feet are really sore.
My thoughts on heels
are very much the same
as they were in the beginning.
That they're stupid.
- I'm the only one who
hasn't taken these off yet.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I just want to point that out.
- Well (bleep) you and
your leather heels man.
- We're walking to lunch now.
Well, some of us are walking,
some of us are waddling.
- Limping.
- Literally limping.
Oh, wait. This is uphill and I don't
like it at all. (car horn honking)
Thank you.
- [voiceover] Hello?
- First catcall!
- Woot! Woot!
- It's hard to keep it together.
Oh, there's (bleep)!
I'm stepping in (bleep).
- That's a riot.
- The struggle is (bleep) real.
(laughing)
- He looks like a damn tyrannosaurus rex.
- I'm done.
Ew! Put that back in your shoe!
That is disgusting!
- The whole side of my foot is blistered.
- Ew!
What hurts the most, ya'll?
The balls of my feet.
- The balls of my feet hurt a lot.
- My pride. My pride probably
hurts the most of all.
- [voiceover] Oh my
God, my leg (laughing).
- [voiceover] Yeah, dude.
- He's got involuntary muscles spasms.
- My legs are giving out on me.
- Come on Ryan!
- We would shut it down!
- Let's do it!
- Let's go have a fun time!
- Something to drink.
- Hey, hey!
- [voiceover] Oh my God.
Mom, aunties, cousins,
sisters that I don't have.
- Women in general.
I applaud you, so highly.
- You know, honestly,
I've never got heels.
I've never understood why girls wear them.
I think they look just
as good without them.
- Go Ryan!
Eh!
- No, I don't think that wearing heels
makes a girl more attractive.
I think being comfortable
makes you attractive.
- But I will say,
when you take that shit off,
it's like a damn orgasm.
(upbeat music)